for the tampa bay rays rich hill looking
to put an end to this losing streak he's
making his 15th start of the season
already
five and two on the record 3.64 earned
run average and
and for rich here tonight this boston
lineup he's gonna have to throw the
kitchen sink at him as far as his looks
fastball's elevated curveball you're
gonna see him drop down you're gonna see
maybe a few more change-ups than normal
a pitch that he just started throwing
here
more and more recently but rich hill
needs to kind of empty the tank and try
to dig the rays out of this hole
he's gonna have to do is work all over
the four quadrants of the strike zone
and strike three call
[Applause]
three pitches one away 14 home runs now
46 runs batted in
this one is lifted into right
back toward the corner and that ball is
a fair ball and caught out there by
margot here comes xander bogart's 323
with 13 home runs
2-2 coming he's gonna poke that one
through for a base hit
here comes verdugo rounding third margot
up and gunning up the line he sailed the
throw
and the red sox leaded one to nothing
but a bad back throw
by margaux and backed up poorly also by
hill
i mean i don't know what position he was
in right there but he wasn't where that
throw was going
well our starting pitchers are presented
by baycare for the boston red sox here
tonight
it's going to be right-hander garrett
richards making his 15th start of the
season even up on the record
era of 4.36 in 74 innings
74 and a third innings of work you can
see that walk total can be
troublesome especially against this
raised lineup that is very patient and
more than willing
to take their walks and work deep counts
with three men on the right side that
ball
grounded into short right
hernandez out there from second base
stationed perfectly
here is juan de franco is just so
advanced for 20 years old
and i think wayne there you go you take
ball four he walked to lead off
or in his first at-bat last night and i
think it
you can tie that in with his bat speed
and we saw it last night
his bat is so quick through the zone
that he doesn't have to start his swing
as quickly as you do
austin meadows and a long one
high and deep and out of here
home run for austin meadows
and the rays grabbed the lead number 16
from meadows
to juan ray
anna renfro smacks a base in into left
field on the first pitch he gets from
rich hill here in the second inning
with the red sox trailing tampa bay two
to one
swing again fastball
gets by santana out on strikes
ray's lead 2-1
that'll bring up mike zanino one man out
two to one tampa bay
and he sends this one deep down the line
and that one is gone
full run for mark zadino mike senino
hits his 15th home run of the year in
the race with a pair
of two-run home runs have built a 4-1
lead
and here is wander franco
the chopper to the right side hernandez
with a double pump and
makes a bad throw bounced it in and the
run scores how about that
that's why you hustle you never know
what may happen
and a swing and a miss a big strikeout
right there
leaving two men aboard 5-1 rays
and the 1-1 puts it in play a little
tapper to dulbeck he'll flip onto the
bag
get the out there
now number three five one tampa bay
[Applause]
and a cup well
he turned in exactly what he was after a
one two three low pitch inning
wander franco will lead off the bottom
of the fourth
in the 3-1 pitch and he'll go up the
middle
hernandez up and over good inning for
rios he gets him one two three
[Music]
three two high
fly ball down the right side margaux
and the foul territory is there to make
the catch
to retire the side with two men left
and the rage leading five to one
two he's gonna swing and pop this one up
devers with the grab side retired one
left
vasquez and the high chop
short stop franco throws a strike to
first
to get vasquez and i'll tell you those
can be some unnerving plays because you
got to wait for that high
chop to come down wait for it wait for
it position yourself
and now grab and throw he does it
extremely well two down
and a 2-2 to [ __ ] he'll rope that one
on the move or rosa rainey can't get it
it'll short hop defense
[ __ ] on his way into second base so red
sox have not had a hit in a while since
the third inning and they've got a
double
[Applause]
did he go yes he did and the toss down
to first from zamino to choi
dulbeck is out of there
swinging he's going to hook this fly
ball into left routine play for verdugo
he's got it
and they will strand two
bogarts has been on base three times
with a single and two walks
and lifts the first pitch into right
center
it's gonna be margaux and
the red sox are out in the seventh 5-1
tampa bay brandon lau he shoots it deep
into center field santana on the run
and that ball is gone first pitch
three-run home run for brandon loud
breaks it open for the raise making it
eight to one
that's going to be a base head that got
past
the leaping window grunts going to score
vasquez gets a base hit the run batted
in
and out away from putting an end to this
losing stretch jd martinez pops it up
foul joy is after it he's got it in the
raise went it
defeating boston 8-2 to snap
this seven-game losing streak